moi je suis un peu décontenané parce
qu'on passe des heures à s'expliquer sur
ce sujet encore une fois faut ramener le
sujet à à des vraies proportions on
n'hésite pas à dire les atrocités on l'a
dit avec des mots qui sont qu'on juge
précis d'accord on n'empêche aucun média
d'utiliser le mot terroriste les médias
sont nos clients encore une fois on
s'adresse pas au grand public on
s'adresse au médias les médias ils
veulent des choses extrêmement précis
précises ils veulent savoir qui parle
sur le la qualification du Hamas comme
organisation terroriste comme la dit
Phil le sud global on va le dire comme
ça ne ne reconnaît pas le Hamas comme
organisation terroriste ça compte ça
compte donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait on dit
le Hamas qui est reconnu comme
organisation terroriste par l'Union
européenne les États-Unis et Israël et
cetera et cetera et qui par ailleurs ne
reconnaît pas le droit d'Israël à
exister bon s où est le problème les
médias sont assez grands pour faire ce
qu'ils veulent derrière donc vous aurez
euh le monde qui ira dire que c'est un
groupe terroriste peut-être tel autre
média dans une autre région ne le
qualifiera pas de tel et choisira ses
mots mais les les médias sont assez
grands pour le faire et les médias je je
n'ai pas connaissance peut-être qu'en
faisant cette déclaration je vais voir
je vais appeler à des à des réactions
mais les médias ne ne ne nous ont fait
aucun pour eux c'est c'est ce n'est pas
un sujet donc on on est on monte en
épingle un sujet depuis des semaines qui
c'est quand même dingue c'est dingue
faut
arrêter à aucun moment on ne ni les
atrocités du 7 octobre on on vous dit
que même lors des attentats de Charlie
sur notre sol F était rédacteur en chef
la c'était une directrice de
l'information française qui était à
l'époque le débat était tranché en ce
sens il y a pas eu de polémique il y a
pas eu de polémique donc pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y en aurait une aujourd'hui